Speaker 1: There are people gleefully
cheering that serial rapist and child
sex offender Larry Nassar has been stabbed in
prison. Now, if you don't remember this story,
I'm going to tell you about it. And I do
have a lot to say about the reactions of
some NBC News reports. Larry Nassar was stabbed
multiple times at Florida federal prison. Union
official says Nassar was sentenced to decades
in prison for sexually assaulting gym gymnasts,
including Olympic medalist. This.
This guy was the osteopathic physician
who was just absolutely disgusting. He's referred
to as a disgraced sports doctor over many,
many, many years. He sexually assaulted numerous
athletes that were supposedly under his care,
although it wasn't very caring what he did. And
in fact, he was convicted on endless counts.
He was stabbed in federal prison, 59 years old,
stabbed twice in the neck, twice in the back, six
times in the chest, sustained a collapsed lung.
Reportedly, he is stable. Okay. So listen, there
are tons of people cheering about this. And often
when sex offenders are hurt or raped or assaulted
in prison, you see this reaction, oh, this is
great. He's getting what he deserves. Pedophiles
don't get treated very well in prison. Remember
Trump even joking about, oh, he's going to become
someone's bride in prison or something like that.
This is not the progressive reaction. And this is
not me saying, oh, I'm offended. I'm offended
that somebody said that. It's not about that.
Okay. You can't complain about how dysfunctional
our prisons are and our incarceration status quo
is. And then rejoice in this. And I'll tell you
what I mean. I understand saying, you know what,
It's hard to find a lot of feeling bad for Larry
Nassar. This guy is one of the worst of the worst.
I don't feel bad that this happened. Okay. Listen,
I'm not asking you to go out of your way and cry
because Larry Nassar was stabbed. And I understand
that what he did is disgusting. And in some sense
you can say, well, he deserves to suffer. And
the suffering is that he's going to be in prison
likely for the rest of his life. But I urge you
to reconsider the gleeful reaction when convicted
sex offenders are attacked or assaulted in prison.
No matter what our feelings are about the offender
and this guy is the worst of the worst. When
we rejoice in their being hurt in prison,
we are doing something that is completely counter
to our views. Prisons, stabbings and rapes are not
part of the punishment prescribed by the law. And
so therefore, when someone is sentenced to prison,
that's their punishment. They're sentenced to
prison and then they're stabbed or beaten up or
raped or whatever the case may be. It's evidence
that our prisons are failing. Our prisons are
failing to keep prisoners safe. This is something
bad. It's not something to be celebrated because
violence in prison isn't justice, it's actually
injustice. And if you look at any other
country where incarceration rates and prison
conditions make sense to us as progressives,
prisoners are safe. It's a violation of human
rights. It's a breach of the rule of law, and it's
a threat to public safety when the prisons are
so. Dysfunctional, that people are attacked and
assaulted in this way. Violence in prison is also
not going to be part of the rehabilitation that
as progressives, we say, listen, we we want there
to be an aspect of rehabilitation in prison. Now,
I am not naive and believe everybody can be
rehabilitated. I don't believe that. But certainly
violence in prison and prison rape aren't even
plausibly part of that rehabilitation. And also,
when we cheer for prison violence, we're
essentially endorsing a culture of brutality,
revenge and vigilantism that is not only
dehumanizing. Again, it's against what we say we
want our prison system to be. So I would encourage
everybody who has been happy about this and there
have been many to think about it a different
way. We should be outraged not about Larry Nassar
specifically, but about the fact that our prisons
lack total human dignity and they lack human
rights. And much the same way that I'm against
the death penalty, not because I think serial
murderers are great people who should have fun
lives going to baseball games. But because when we
support the death penalty, we are supporting
killing by the state. And I don't support
that. We're supporting revenge by the state,
and I don't support that. So it's not about
Larry Nassar. It's about as progressives, we
want, at minimum adequate security and health
care and proper nutrition in prison. Okay. And
then we can talk about education, counseling,
actual rehabilitation, etc.. Let's not be happy
about this. It's just weird when I see supposed
progressives happy about this. And it is, you
know, Larry Nassar should get to miserably serve
out his sentence in a box for the things that
he did, but he should not be stabbed. That's
evidence of the failings of our prison system. If
you disagree with me, let me know and make sure
you're subscribed on YouTube, YouTube.com,
slash the David Pacman show and make sure
you're following me on threads. I'm on threads at
David Dot Pacman. Quick break. Back after this.